[Music]
in tone-deaf news you were still our key
that was better than Fergie submitted by
love from Wakanda black pant Oh black
hands our group of third graders are
selling ar-15 raffle tickets as a
fundraiser for their baseball teams
every team raffle so if you win it you
win a ar-15 yep what [ __ ] date
Mazzara raffle tickets are five dollars
or five tickets for $20 thank you for
your support
Bobcats so this is the gun right orgmen
well that's pretty sick
obtain the SB tactical race I like that
one any of you guys would enjoy this
better it got some good parts on there
okay and that's a geotextile on their
rap man cool this thing alone is like a
[ __ ] ton of money by itself what if
we're all looking at this wrong and
they're just giving you that poster oh
just the poster you're hanging around
then this would not be news yeah but to
put into perspective that's like a
Mercedes or rifles though it's pretty
good
oh that looks like Beamer like Texas
it's pretty nice so it was a nice
donation by whoever donated it but
tone-deaf because of exactly because the
recent shooting oh it's not good to do
that right now so the recent shooting
that happen in Florida well there's a
bunch or the same type of weapon you
know what the problem with like
combining the two and I kind of like
tying them two together and America
there's only like a couple of rifle
systems so if whether you do good or bad
like the police use the same thing the
bad guys are gonna use the same thing so
I don't like it how you tie one thing
and they give this whole thing like a
like a bad name it's like duh the
computer hacker used an iPhone it's like
[ __ ] everyone has iPhone of
course not use iPhone right now you give
iPhones a bad name no I think it's
because that shooting thing just
happened yeah and there everyone's like
well how the [ __ ] did he get it why was
it so easy or they said it was a
different rifle like if they gave away
like an ak-47 day when bsp
I think they're saying not to give away
it rifle yeah third grade baseball team
like it's like kid guns in school
shooting was it adults that participate
in the raffle and then they get the gun
or is it the kids that are gonna win the
gun question but I'm assuming it would
be adults that would get the gun and I'm
also trying to stay open-minded and be
culturally sensitive so I don't know how
it is in Missouri but there are states
where there are elementary shooting
teams because it's a sport so if that's
the case it's like giving away a
basketball to so I don't want to like
jump the gun and like and just judge
them for this I think it's a lot like
giving away a basketball yeah they did
mention that they've been doing they've
been doing me the rifle or like gun
raffles for the the teams for many many
years yeah they're just saying like it's
normal for them but then based off of
just what happened recently that's why
they're saying that this is just
tone-deaf I don't know man
there's 300 million guns in America like
the idea being that we should be seeing
so many [ __ ] shootings it's insane but
we don't but they always meme it up in
the media whenever something like this
happens everybody with an ar-15 now has
to feel like [ __ ] about themselves yeah
like hey I was kind of part of that
school shooting today like I don't like
any of that video I went around is the
guy that sawed apart his his rifle
because he was saying that he owns this
one gun but he could easily get rid of
the gun and sell it make money off of it
but then what if later on down the line
someone's kid gets a hold of the gun or
like that gun ends up killing someone
else he's like I can't that's [ __ ] ass
- we could word it fall dead cuz if he's
a responsible gun owner it'd be locked
up in a safe and no one would ever get
ahold of it right but he was just saying
from what I gathered in that video he
was just saying like if I was ever
irresponsible no he has a right to do
whatever you want one less gun in the
world yet there's millions of guns but
at least my gun won't won't be
responsible well that makes me feel
comfortable it's a virtuous seemingly
[ __ ] [ __ ] man he did it for the meme
and for like the Instagram post or the
Facebook post I get it's his real
feelings and [ __ ] but the impact is
[ __ ] zero it's like me having like
let's say I had like coffee or something
I'm like you know what I'm gonna destroy
this cup so it doesn't [ __ ] doesn't give
someone else caffeine withdrawal
it's like yeah I'm gonna describe
another caffeine thing like this has no
impact whatsoever he's probably trying
to start the impact where like other
guys will go okay well let me solve my
AR in half by the way like I can't do
that cuz that's a lot of money
well most people just go like you know
they get home from work or school or
whatever the hell they turn on the TV
and they see something terrible happens
on the news right and then the way the
news is talking it's like well hey just
because I like have a gun now I'm a
piece of [ __ ] gun gun owner I'm killing
kids is what they're making it sound
like it's crazy that's the part that
kind of gets me like what the [ __ ] like
I'm a law-abiding citizen yeah I talk a
lot of [ __ ] on JK news but at the same
time what I actually do in real life is
I do all the legal [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ]
really square guy why am i demonized for
having this hobby because of other news
like you were saying and they do it
every single hour and they show the same
[ __ ] over and over and then they have
the witnesses and they have the
testimonials and it's like yeah I might
keep that and they just make it so bad
you would think that we like as an
American you would think that we've all
somehow seen gun violence like in our
neighborhoods or in our lives or like
all the time you see it right right but
but I'm just saying the amount of gun
incidents compared to the amount of guns
that are owned is it's like nil man like
knowledgeable statistically [ __ ]
crazy small the way that they blow it up
that it seems like it's a big thing and
even the way that they classify what a
school shooting is is is they change the
parameters for that which is why all of
a sudden looks like school shootings are
going up because if an incident with a
gun happens and like it's like three or
more under people are involved they
consider that now a school shooting a
massacre or whatever for more people
right and they change that because it
used to be more people than that hmm but
it's always like there are that many
people somehow involved with it doesn't
even mean they die esse Sara Lee it's
like a thing or a hit so it could just
be like some kids shooting as like gangs
or something or whatever but they call
that like a massacre they don't give a
[ __ ] about that though I do think
solutions are [ __ ] up though Chicago
is like there's there's 23 killings like
a weekend in Chicago with from gun
violence and nobody gives a [ __ ] but
when white people get killed
in Florida it's a big fiasco yeah again
everybody got to get rid of their guns
now yeah say you're old you're a woman
right and just say I was let's pretend
that you're a woman it's pretend for a
minute cuz you're just one of the guys
to me yeah if I'm an attacker there is
nothing in the world that more equalizes
you to me than you having a gun you
having the ability to put me down to
stop me yeah but because something
happened in Florida that is [ __ ] up
and then we all think sucks and then we
all hate and we all abort and if
anything I want I would love to have
heard that that kid got killed on his
way in like not not getting hurt I
security go by a security guard with a
gun or somebody yeah but because of that
you now have to have your your potential
like equalizer taken from you because it
could have been used somehow in a
terrible way somewhere down the road I
don't like it the counter-argument there
where they're saying that more people
with guns don't necessarily equal more
safety because there's one in instance
that I read that's not even the
counter-argument though so this this one
instance happened in Walmart right there
was a gunman there there were other
customers there that had guns and so
they started trying to get a hold of the
situation but then once police got there
it took way longer to figure out who are
the good guys who are the bad guys cuz
everyone had guns and then I just ended
up I think the gunman got away or
something but yeah like instances like
that that's what a lot of arguments are
being brought up right now where they're
saying well it's not necessarily a good
thing well there are also instances
where like somebody was about to shoot
up you remember exactly that church
shooting that guy got shot right the guy
took him out yeah there are so isolated
incidents it's not gonna be it's not
gonna make sense for 300 million people
yeah you don't just never generalize one
of the arguments that I hear from mainly
like California City people right is why
do we need a gun why do we need why do
we need a hunt what like it's not an
everyday thing that they need but but
say that to the Arizona cattle rancher
that lives by the border and has to deal
with cartel people on a daily basis
that come in and [ __ ] go into their
towns and like it's the wine when they
call the cops it's so spread out it
takes 30 minutes
plus we don't we hear in the media all
the time you can't trust police because
police are racist like you like police
or you can't trust a cop necessarily
well now okay let's let's give the cops
all the weapons and then we can't
protect ourselves in our communities
like this is the kind of [ __ ] where I my
it's a [ __ ] logical fallacy it makes
no goddamn sense how long does it take
the cops to come like 10 to 30 minutes
then when the cop comes can you trust
the cop cuz we're told in the media you
can't necessarily do that right so it's
like oh I'm sorry like we should take
all guns away from say minorities say
women yeah we'll trust the government to
do it and the kind of police to do it
but don't we also criticize them all the
time because they can't do it right I
have a friend who's a volunteer police
officer for the state of New Mexico so
he lives out here in California but he's
a volunteer officer he goes there
seasonally to do some cop work because
they have a low amount of like I guess
officers and in the towns by the border
and he says that the the safer thing for
them to do is just let the cartels drive
through because guys if they pull them
over those these guys are just armed
they're like the military they don't
care so then so if the cops can't do
that imagine being like a regular
citizen and then people ask the question
why do you need an ar-15 because you
don't understand that there are people
in the US with real threats and dangers
like that you don't know who's coming
through your door any more than they
know what you have either yeah to me
it's not necessarily your right to know
what I have as long as I don't I'm not
saying like everyone should have [ __ ]
bump stocks and all this [ __ ] I don't
want that yeah I'm down with them
banning that right like it should be
like you hold down the trigger and it's
like you know no one needs a fully auto
like they don't even use that in the
military no it's impractical right so
that that makes sense but also when
people make this argument and go okay
why do you need 30 rounds well what if
there's 10 people breaking into your
home like people assume that it's gonna
be one burglar or like one person coming
in and you only need 10 bullets for that
and it's like how can you be so sure
people that haven't been in a gun fight
they don't know that the average is six
to eight bullets per person my whole
thing is this simple right if you wanted
to go get cocaine right now could you
100%
it's illegal though yes so okay let's
say guns are now illegal
well there's 300 million of them out
there so now you created a black market
for guns that is like gonna be [ __ ] a
billion dollar industry how do you
confiscate all of that you can't because
they did that in Australia and that's
one of the arguments that I hear is a 92
yeah in 1900 the ships you can control
the airplane like the globe but we have
Canada and Mexico you can't control our
land you can't get the gun you can't
pick up our guns and take them you have
to zoom in on the Australian statistic
tube to find a correlation between them
confiscating guns and that gun violence
went down because what actually happened
was that the violence for a had an
uptick and then it continued the
thirty-year trend down it was already
trending down from the way that society
had evolved and people were moving in
their own communities and everything was
like getting better and better
and so there was less gun violence and
so when they banned guns it was after an
incident then there was a slight uptick
and then it just continued its way down
so we don't necessarily know that that
means oh because they outlawed guns now
we know that it's because it all went
down but that's not true
like that's not or that's not a fair
it's not causation they don't know right
they don't know it's so complicated
because it's been a part of just us
culture and history for so freaking long
you know a lot of people that want this
nationwide ban to happen like I don't
really understand being they understand
the depth - how deep this is well a lot
of these same people it's public figures
celebrities on Twitter right they have
armed guards they have like people who
protect their gated homes and [ __ ] yeah
but then the rest of us like they
actually need that is how they feel
because they're celebrities the rest of
us we don't need to protect ourselves
the same way because it's bad for the
world
but like of course these mighty people
from on high can protect themselves
however they want with the same guns
that we want I'm also for a ban or for
more laws if they're specific if they're
not these general Blake gets Damon's we
got up and guns because I've never heard
of a happy person killing a ton of
people it's almost like someone that
wasn't mentally stable with a gun
someone on medication for
antidepressants or whatever it's the
person behind the gun and so if we're
just banning the gun it doesn't really
solve the problem they're going to
two hands on a bow and arrow cross beurs
van a van they're still gonna kill
[ __ ] fertilizer they can make
bombs like give me a break but if you
can make it harder for people that are
mentally unstable or that are prone to
violence to get a guy on four I'm all
for that I'm for solutions that actually
make logical sense rather why not have
armed guards in schools why the hell not
yeah why not that's a great idea
Carranza landscaping I guess to have
like a elephant and then have a guy like
what Saul swatted out right but I'm for
that
or metal detectors or whatever the case
may be both people make the argument to
that Japan is a super safe country and
they don't have guns and I'm like well
have you been to Japan and have you seen
how the culture is it's totally
different everyone lines about the
escalator hey you know what's do yeah so
it's different because in a place like
us where you have unarmed people robbing
you jacking you [ __ ] jumping you it's
like this is a different culture yeah
this is a place where I feel unsafe and
antidepressants are numbing the [ __ ] out
of people yeah we have Black Friday
where people jump each other to get a
[ __ ] deal on a VCR and they can't
even stay online in an orderly fashion
in Japan anytime there's a group they
already start forming a line on the
right side it's very orderly I don't
think you compare the culture like that
when [ __ ] Fukushima happened
the Mafia there came with truckloads of
water to support people how was the
Crips did that I mean all right and say
like well there's no guns in Japan well
it starts with the people - if I felt
safe here and I felt like culturally it
was just a totally different environment
I'll be like fine but a lot of these
people on Twitter and [ __ ] like there
they're chilling in sweet mega mansions
dude they're protected as hell and like
even my friends of mine who are anti-gun
and they want all the guns to be taken
away from people they live in great
communities and [ __ ] Beverly Hills
like they don't give a [ __ ]
yeah don't worry about a bump in the
night or a break you know if if their
window breaks they think a bird flew
into it
Pelican again we live downtown like
right next to Skid Row and I don't
necessarily always feel safe but I don't
really like the amount of guns that we
have I just know there's nothing that we
can do about it but I do think that
there should be more laws and just we
need to probably round up and melt
some of these really like really
dangerous ones I'm cool with whatever
the specific legislation is to be
discussed like what is it yeah it needs
to be specific that's the thing like the
pump stock thing I'm like yes let's get
rid of bump stock they didn't for
example like people don't know how to
differentiate what is dangerous and what
isn't so a lot of it is cosmetic most
people will look at and say that's a
dangerous looking one that's an assault
rifle or whatever but it could have the
same it's single shooter dude yeah it
could be the same thing as a hunting
even the name of it is [ __ ] a ar-15
well assault rifles oh yeah yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] that's a weird but really
it's just a majority of it is just
cosmetic and it just looks cool and the
the media blatantly lies about the ships
yes they make it sound like if you just
hold the trigger down it's going dead
that the dud and that's not the case
that's not what it does it doesn't do
that at all and like let's say you ban
all guns right and you have someone
that's like held a premeditated like
this guy he's been planning for years
whatever he can master the bow and arrow
literally and probably shoot off more
arrows than you can bullets so like what
do you do then so I still for me it's I
still feel like it's more on the mental
health where we need to keep people that
are mentally unstable away from weapons
rather than focus on the weapons
themselves cuz then the crossbow hanging
out that big five isn't doing jack [ __ ]
it's just chilling them yeah I mean the
gun thing school shooting thing is only
happening more now because of the media
attention probably so that people so
like being you know their name they're
treated like [ __ ] like antihero yeah
like you know everything about them the
day like the night of I mean we've
always had a lot of guns right by the
way the FBI like visited this kid or
like I'm sorry he said he wanted to like
be the next great school shooter on a
[ __ ] YouTube video yeah nobody looks
into it yeah the media can find you
remember some kid made a mean they made
like a meme of Donald Trump like
suplexing I'm like like CNN or something
and they [ __ ] Doc's this kid they
found the kid they found out who he was
they made them apologize but the FBI
couldn't find a guy on a youtube comment
who used his own name
I mean how do you know I mean people
troll YouTube comments all the time
nobody they were called like why is he
needed no they were contacted yeah to
report it and the FBI didn't do [ __ ]
that's the thing that is disturbing not
to mention the police visited this
location like the kids house like 38
times or something they don't ever
examine the flip side so for example we
have driver's ed in high school right
imagine that it was like guns ed in high
school where everyone is taught to
handle firearms in a very safe way safe
way if you pick up a gun any rifle off
the ground you feel very confident you
know how to use it then I think we have
so much more awareness we're not going
to view this as like this threat and I
think then we would have a different
approach to guns because when we have
like drivers accidents we don't try to
ban all cars
nobody ever the way that their
fear-mongering I don't I'm opposed to it
I think if we can all just be more
educated about it then we'll make more
sound decisions rather than even during
drunk driving where people nobody tries
to ban alcohol what happens when drunk
drivers happen right it's like a drunk
driver killed people and then every
single time like it's like don't drink
and drive
right yeah it's like why can't it be
this specific with this why does it have
to be ban all the guns yeah
and I'm cool people who are like hey I
want like you were saying right you're
like I want specific legislation well
what is it I want to hear it then we can
have a real conversation on what parts
of the gun should be modified or what
shouldn't just to make people happy what
politicians do is they put all these
unnecessary things on the gun or like it
doesn't do anything it doesn't change it
at all you're like hollow sites we're
banning hollow sites or whatever yeah
it's like a bullet button or whatever
and it's like what does this do it just
it doesn't change it
[Music]